i i really liked your idea about not
saying the same thing twice the same way
that's that's a real interesting mental
habit uh disciplinary habits that's
smart like what's what's 4 to the power
4
256 okay so how do you know that you can
memorize it but another way is that you
can go well what's 4 to the power 5.
well that's 2 to the power 10 that's 10
24 if you're a computer scientist you
know that because you deal with bits and
then you can say well what's 2 so what's
4 to the power 365. so you can bound it
from each side 4 to the power 3 4 to the
power 5 and then you get a better
understanding of what it means to be 4
to the power 4. so the more
even if it's slight alterations and
you're of saying the same phenomenon of
sorry of trying to describe the same
phenomenon you get a better
understanding of it and when you're
talking about something so complex i'd
i never give the same lecture twice
yeah that's not easy man no
but it's uh it's pretty damn
entertaining i'll tell you
yeah so before we go i'm curious why it
is that you why is it that you do these
podcasts
what are you trying to accomplish with
them so one is obviously you're trying
to learn and obviously you've attained
some level of fame and wealth so it's
not as if you want more perhaps you do i
mean we can't discount selfish
motivations but what is the reason that
you hope the good reason in you is
to have conversations like this and to
share them with as many people as
possible in the hopes that we'll build
better people and not burn the world
down
yeah
yeah some people say well why is it that
i'm focusing on the left and you
mentioned it's not
see some people caught fun from the left
called the right reactionary well so it
seems like perhaps what you're doing on
the extreme left you can even if you
feel like the right is more damaging you
don't think you're provoking the right
also the left is more amenable to reason
and at least colloquially it's more
amenable to reasons so i thought perhaps
i should pursue that and i'm more
interested the right is blatant in the
racism so it's like well that's a five
minute film if i'm to analyze the right
and
yeah so i'll just i'll let people know
about
if they'd like to see
more about me they can visit theories of
everything so you can just type that
into youtube there are conversations
much like this jordan where i'm super
so fascinated no i wouldn't say my
motivations are are pure i'm fascinated
by consciousness physics free will and
god
and
and
and exploring them with technical depth
as much as i can and not
desprising like most people
i think that disparagement is what
well in many ways is holding us back so
i'm trying to bring some rigor some
exactitude to it because not that's
actually well
we can talk about that and then for
better left unsaid if people want to see
you can go to
betterleftonsetfilm.com that i try to
bring some of the same analytical
framework to exploring the concept of
not exploring the question of when does
the left go too far and it's such an
incomplete film i disavow it in many
ways because it's
it's so incomplete but it's almost like
homework i have to submit it at some
point